welcome to your mom's house
i'm christina and this is Tom my husband
hey how's it going god no Christina
Christina Christina okay yeah
dan this is a you this is so exciting to
us you have no idea I mean I know you've
seen the the footage of us talking about
you we're huge fans and this is just
just a thrill for us so and you look
amazing you do you look like you're
about 6 1 to 25 and you can kill a bear
without your fucking knife I know I
believe it 71 I believe it men so you
know we obviously became huge fans
watching the YouTube clips and you know
we we love your direct style
I'm always also my my whole life been a
fan of successful people I've always
tried to emulate them try to learn from
them you know I've been reading Forbes
and fortune since I was a kid so I felt
like you were like a mix match for me of
like I felt like you were some football
coaches I've had successful people I've
been around and then teachers and
professors that were very direct so we
really like and we also opted beyond us
as comedians we like people that have a
kind of loose tongue that don't really
hold back on some of the expletives
so I'll just say you know 20 years ago
or what I founded and I was thinking
about something to do some of my close
friends at the time and
today because I'm quite funny said Dan
want to be a stand-up comic well I think
you would have a future yeah you
definitely had a future
hey can we ask this and I know a lot of
this avail is available online I know
people can check out the site but just
you know for the listener who's
downloading right now what is the
backstory of you being the fifty billion
dollar man what what is the origin of
that okay I've got a big mouth I wasn't
going to be asked to be on any boards
and I was correct in that assessment so
I taught a year at Cal State Northridge
an honors class and I have found that
very fulfilling tonight I thought the
students were all fucking worthless and
so my my very good friend that I've
known since we're kids said Dan you know
why don't you go back there's a lot of
charlatans in the print one was called
the personal development business 1992
and you know why don't we re-engineer
reverse engineer how you turned eight
hundred and twenty dollars four hundred
fifty million Wow
in eight years so we sat down and we are
we engine if we reverse engineered it
came up with steps actually seven steps
which is still used and then I went out
and take a look at the competition so I
spent seven eight months going to
everybody seminar paying five grand in
some cases two fifteen eighteen nineteen
of the Guru's at that time many of which
are still around and the I realized that
nobody talking about right yes and
nobody had created money oh they put
acid on seminar seats and at that time
selling tapes in books good sure I lost
my career in May of 1993 at the Sheraton
hotel downtown
Los Angeles can I had about 300 people
that paid a hundred or a thousand
dollars apiece 300 Wow whoa
and I say well fuck twenty-two seminars
in a row across the great country of
America and every time I give a seminar
with less people and every time I give a
seminar there's less people so but um I
got out of the twenty twenty-one
twenty-two there was guys right and
there was no social media so I decided
that I was gonna I try to figure out
what my USB was a unique selling
proposition and a one I turned 800 bucks
into corn 50 million - I live in a
castle that I own we phrase it a trust
that I own homes and I went down these
things and I went out and looked at the
competition again I said I couldn't
understand so in between the seminar and
I didn't tell people that it was hard
for me to me the money I did because it
was I find it quite easy because one of
the questions I'm often asked dan why
don't you just continue to make a lot of
fucking money for yourself and I mean
quite frankly and I told the kids at
Oxford University two months ago
I find it easy guys is how fucking hard
it was to get people with low
self-esteem right know that have been
raised by your parents yes Amen yes Amen
because this generation is that created
over 50 billion
dollars in equity for addictions run
fucking bombs right gosh it's coming
about numbers a lot but not everybody
wants notoriety but basically their name
use so the fifty billion that I talk
about are just the people that that
allow me the privilege of using their
names and so that's so you been how's
coach people reasons yeah okay so I
coach people away free yeah I don't need
the money right so we started giving
everything away free and as I just said
in that little short clip we just put
out it is the last excuse for the cunts
not to use it because I went for the
most expensive product on the internet
free and so the only thing I do is if
you want to be metric by me personally
you come to the castle and you pay but
99.999% of everybody that is benefit of
qlae I never met I never Skype up
Facebook or tweet but wow that's a lot
of fun till now yeah let me ask you oh
yeah sure I'm dying to know Dan why are
people so fucking poor pretty good
nailed it that's pretty good well you
didn't have a from from what I've
gleaned about your child and time
sitting at hotels I know
yeah but somehow I managed the Sabre I
stay productive then I stay productive
you know it fuels my business it feels
my material but your your uh your
upbringing was from what you say pretty
rough like your dad was in law
enforcement and you caught it you credit
your letter and you go left or left
around first the first stadium way exit
Elysian Park area yeah
and then my dad my mother and my
grandmother
swam across the hues of the whatever
that river is down by I got Houston real
way Wow yeah my mother my grandmother
would die they're not alive now we die
from me telling that story that's true
yeah
so you're Mexican Mexican American
immigrants correct and one was born in
the United States but the strangely
enough my parent we're not raising it my
dad was a cop he worked a couple extra
jobs to put food on our table without me
cops to make very much money back in the
50s and in the early 60s and so the my
mother pressured my dad and move away
from East LA to the valley and a house
we couldn't afford to get me away from
he's still a now you you wonder how much
trouble could I get me still a young kid
well plenty I had broken a kid's arm in
several places on purpose yeah I smashed
a guy glasses into a dike and most a
glass in her eyes fortunately it was his
sight and the coup de Gras was I dropped
aquarium from the second floor on my
teacher and if he hadn't moved six
inches it would have killed me but it
only broke his collarbone move now my
mother knew I was just getting started
yeah I was still in grammar school god
only knows what I do by the time I got
out so she she pressured my dad and we
moved about Wow late hey I want to ask
you this and of course you may have
mentioned it before but I just don't
know what drew you to to the UK and to
getting a castle I mean we all know that
like you know there's no obviously
castles awesome on earth but I mean like
there's something specifically make you
want to go ahead and do that 30 miles
down the road why I looked at a lot of
estates and this is the one that I know
shortest August of 84 and the I knew
that this is where I wanted to be I also
knew that if I wanted to change my
lifestyle completely I had to get out of
my environment is my environment my
family even though they're great people
and you know they're teachers firemen
policemen that kind of thing
there was no hydrants economically
high-performance people and I had I've
been stationed in Europe with NATO as an
army officer and I saw that it was a
different way of life and so I decided
to come to the UK originally in 1981 and
then permanently and 1984 Wow well
that's interesting you mentioned the
influence of your family because you
also talk about show me your friends
I'll show your future and that you're
the some you are the some of the three
people that essentially raised you is
that is that our it right so yeah where
that comes from for you yeah think about
it it's your mother
normally maybe your dad if he's not
working or gone in maybe an older
brother
maybe a grandmother or herb a problem
that's normally the some of the people
who raised you
now who in that group are and I know
your dad was a hard-ass yes you know
yeah from my dad's generation probably
yes your generation yes was ready for or
educated for growing you up to be a
high-performance highly competitive
person in the 21st century probably
nobody right and when people call me old
school I laugh I don't think I'm most
collecting my dad's old school right and
his generation from World War two but I
mean then after you you know self-esteem
is built the first eight years of life
right the Catholic Church said the best
you give me your child the first seven
or eight year than I right that's right
after that show me your friends I'll
show you your future and so normally we
hang around the people are chilled or
whatever the right word is now with
people then were comfortable with which
means people that don't stretch us don't
take us out of our comfort zone right
right right
know what you know and I feel like you
when I when I hear you say that every
time I talk to somebody
see someone who's kind of bummed out
about their current status or you know
they're just kind of dragging
they always almost always hang around
losers you know grab you go well dude
you're kind of you're putting yourself
in that environment to to be where
you're at you got a guy yeah hey Dan
you're a high you're the highest
achiever so who does Dan pain you hang
out with yeah
yeah can we ask you this too because we
talked about it before what's an average
Dan Pena day like what when does the
alarm clock go off what is what is the
average day like and the office which is
about a hundred meet no 75 meters that
way behind me yeah and I checked emails
I take my barriers pills and potions I
have my first cup of coffee I answer
emails and yeah Pena on coffee sounds
scary man I don't know if we need my I
said I know if I need more coffee and
Pena
I think he's got enough going on where I
had my neighbor place I would normally
go in the gym but I haven't been going
in the gym because they have put any
weight on my leg right but maybe I just
started baby for yesterday put an upper
body stuff because I can't use my legs
yeah and then I have an apple a couple
of carrots and normally are some donate
okay that's okay yeah and I continue by
now the rest of the world waking up
right East Coast the United States by
nearly one o'clock and then I have
probably another zoom fuck or sky fuck
and then I had a goal this year if I had
my leg operator on that workout twice a
day so I go back to the gym for 30 or 40
minutes you're fucking nuts come back
and and then I work I have
I mentor about a hundred plus kids for
free for a year after they come to the
seminar Wow so I hope you've got some
fucking headache or some hemorrhoid from
one of them and then towards the end of
the week I'm grading if you will their
weekly reports because I get weekly
reports well from the mentees and then I
which are quite onerous in quite detail
and so I answer them that takes me
normally a day or Dan half wait let's
jump can we jump in there for a second
there so you know we we've seen the
footage online your mentoring we presume
people from all different walks of life
all different types of businesses and
I've seen you say in an interview that
you've had people pass out shit their
pants piss their pants is that because
of the your style and and the level of
pressure you're putting on them and
they're just not you right that's right
right so agree I think you know and use
I believe that the central thing and
because I've read your website and that
fear seems to be the root of all human
fucking failure and the ability to
conquer your your mind and conquer your
fear seems I mean is that central to
what the Dan painted system is yeah
that's right you push through it and you
suck at the fuck up and you move on and
that's how you become successful yeah
did you start to use cunt more as you
when you moved to the UK because I love
it
can I ask you this too
so I know that obviously there's a lot
involved with you know learning from you
so I'm not I'm not asking to summarize
it very shortly but in a way I am and
what I'm asking is if you were just to
say to somebody's saying to you watching
this now or listening and saying why the
fuck can't I be more successful
what's a basic you know lesson to give
somebody who's just looking for that
some boost is there anything okay Wow
that's absolutely because I think some
of us have to undo all the dumb shit we
were taught by our parents that's
basically within and society is that you
kind of have to undo all the bullshit
you know we just have a 10 month old son
and the amount of bullshit now in the
world is so overwhelming I don't even
know what the it's quick like now you
can't even dress your boy up in blue
because that's considered a form of
child abuse because he hasn't decided
his gender preference yet you know and
it's it's and I fear how he's going to
turn out under this fired her we fired
fired or immediately got the boot I
think we almost man I I almost I really
did almost blow a gasket oh yeah can I
ask you one other question how do you
get on the Wall of shame yeah we saw it
in the background
it says Wallace
you have to do something pretty
incredible first of all you have to make
a lot of money and go over to the dark
side and use it in criminality ah
so those are former like people you have
worked with like they're no longer in
obviously right right but I'm saying
they're out and about they're not like
in class at the time so like people that
really fucked up Wow so those are real
fuck-ups of the Wall of shame people
yeah my leading woman what what for like
some you know some scandal like you know
okay so like SEC violations and
everything yeah
lastly because I know we don't have you
much time as always
you look incredible we wanted to know
what's your position on jeans first of
all you know there's aubergines and the
seven or eight guys that I know I could
say that I know yeah and there are more
games the guys that I know because
they're my age or older yeah but I do
what I wear jeans like when I travel I
wear pair jeans shirt best like this or
waistcoat it's both and a blazer like
I've got on I won't have a tie or go
time but the high performance people
yeah we don't have one time to make a
first impression kids one and says about
me or any that shit and have it for many
many years but most people are looking
that are looking for a possible game or
a possible business opportunity or so
something like that you know they're
gonna people are gonna reflect back with
respect to look like my song right right
right absolutely and that's why I tell
people to you know upgrade black first
class you're not going to get a business
deal back in there over the cattle right
and you know and especially since we
came up with these frequent flyer deals
sure is the second million mile on
American Airlines shit thirty years ago
and now I have many miles and I guess
you're different but the but I mean so I
try my best but I I try to look at the
top five percent when I travel oh
definitely cuz you know that are out
there
you know our notoriety people come up
and ask for their autographs you know
which brings up an interesting point for
all the success they've had the I have
the least amount of followers right ah
Twitter kills me yeah
it's weird and should have Lincoln
reason what's that good
I tell it cuz you're a cunt because
you're a fucking right see when I call
you okay okay you want to be liked by
some other yeah right absolutely
the reason I had the fewer people on
those things because people link on to
be on Twitter and they'll see if you my
post and they'll read what I have to say
they're go to my website is about five
just too hard for me so they'll unlink
me or whatever the right word is yeah
yeah considering I'm the only guy that
is I'm a high performance coach the only
guy in the personal development
generally speaking business that has
created any fucking money it gives all
the shit over three
yep why would you buy some guys shit
it hasn't created a fucking dime yeah I
totally agree with you green by the way
one thing we didn't ask earlier what was
that first business that you started
that made all the money that you got
what kind of business was it I started
with 800 bucks
and my first year in business I did 50
million dollars in revenue and he's that
deliver and to acquire oil and gas
companies in a debacle in the oil
industry which is not dissimilar what's
going on when I head out and then I
built the integrated oil company and it
was an office except Petroleum stations
gas station well we were fighting
construction pipeline drilling etcetera
and then my wisdom to me out and so I
walked quite a bit of money but like I
said right right oh yeah but still a lot
of money and and now that was the first
23 years of my life and the last 23
years of my business life anyway I've
been pulling cuts across the goal line
and it's not easy I mean it's a
motherfucker
I believe it could be but I when I saw
you guys talk about me on Rogan program
yeah I was a few I was I was happy but I
was amused because the but joe said you
know that I was dying dead whatever he
says of course I just responded to that
but yeah interesting enough the most
people that come here to see me our guys
that have tried everything else right
they've tried hypnosis they tried drugs
they tried three or four marriages they
tried Scientology they tried every
fucking thing because when they come to
me
and I tell them you got to pay them up
Piper you got it there's a paper ice to
action you've got to sacrifice asshole
and the tried everything you know it's
like you tried everything I try to quit
the smoke quit smoking and now doesn't
work and we have a hundred percent
success track record 100% Wow you know
way to people do people stay in the
castle we significantly increase your
network and and the way we do that it's
significantly increase your self-esteem
oh yeah I believe that so how does
somebody get to stay in the castle and
take your seminar what's the process
like and you come and I give him about
four six times a year I just finished
one a few days ago and I've got another
one in December before my excerpt I'll
have my own damn she's yeah and the by
the way they told me I should wait 18
months because of my age before I had
the second poll knee replacement but
instead I worried about nine weeks
military a couple veterans and then the
rest aspiring entrepreneur we have some
guys which to come they already have
made a lot of money but we had a
neurosurgeon in the last seminar who
makes you know six seven million bucks a
year Jesus which it would be
satisfactory to most people but he knows
in recent years we've had one stand-up
comedian oh really
and he's Trump in New York and I think I
told you I had a cousin who the family
shame because she's right here's well
believe me every comedian has that story
well they see it as risky well I see it
as risky they also see it as they don't
you know they don't usually picture
there who ever saying that they're gonna
try it as
being in the successful portion of it I
think they picture a bum with a mustard
stain you know just having you know
people are choking back a couple beers
and more and they don't realize the
potential right the business of it I
think a lot of people don't know how
comedians actually make money yeah
Christmas rock and of course now he's
doing a big specialty to spend 20 40
million yeah I mean yeah yeah he's at
the top end of it for sure but I mean
look at that guy Kevin Hart
summer me right that is it is there's
there's a full spectrum of we got we got
at least end this right shoot let's try
calling about